i think that you've said a lot of
amazing stuff for the past two years i
think what you just said right there
actually might be one of the most
valuable rants in terms of just money
that you've ever said
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what
what's up it's me sean and sam the
vanilla gorilla
all right we have a good episode today
sean just said he thought this was an
amazing episode we talked about a lot of
different stuff you have a list what do
we talk about
we talked about uh the surprisingly big
business of
greeting cards and e-cards uh we talked
about
the crazy chick-fil-a tech stack and
some ideas around that
and creating a consulting company around
that we talked about this crazy fbi
takedown
where the fbi basically tricked
thousands and thousands of criminals
with a
pretty genius app um what else you did a
good
bump boxes breakdown and bumps a guy
who's built a business that sells uh
subscription boxes to pregnant women and
and uh their their their babies and it's
like 40 million dollars a year
the babies don't buy it they they might
but it's meant for the babies
right that does 40 million a year in
sales and we talked about how
this article that came out about rich
people not paying taxes well we talked
about how they actually get money to
live which was kind of mind-blowing to
me
and we talked about one of my favorite
childhood actors and childhood movies
how that act young child actor has
become a crypto billionaire
and then i got excited saying he's the
billy of the week but that's all to come
in this episode and do me a favor go to
your spotify
go to your itunes there's a button that
says subscribe or
follow follow if you're on spotify
subscribe itunes click that button
because when you click that we go up in
the charts we go in the charts we get
more listeners when we get more
listeners we can record more stuff
please do that thank you and have a good
episode
well first happy birthday you are uh
you're what 31 32 32 now okay great
yeah good i was feeling bad i'm 33 and
you're always like yeah we're basically
the same age we're both 30 31.
well i do it to slight you i do it as a
joke because you're only a year older
than me
but i want to make it clear that you're
all of the be still yeah
yeah yeah and in my head i immediately
stop listening to everything else you
say and i just start thinking in my head
[__] i'm older than sam and then i have
to be like why does that matter who
cares and then i get back
and i don't even know what's going on
yeah 35 okay great
i do it this will feel even worse now um
my my trainer by the way he's at a 40 41
something like that
and he looks great looks like he's 25
and anytime someone's like oh wow i
didn't know that
you know once they find out his age or
whatever he's just like
um he's like i'm living to 105 and he's
constantly watching videos of people who
are
like 105 but healthy or like 100 and
they have like
you know they're still like madly in
love with their husband or wife and he's
just
constantly watching these videos these
outlier examples to be like
that's me i'm going to have that life do
you care about living until you're like
really old
yeah well i tell everyone 1 30. i say
okay great i say i'm gonna be 130 but
i'm gonna
i'm gonna act like a current 70 year old
so like my like the 70 year olds now
that's what i'm going to be when i'm
130.
okay why 130 where is that number from
nice ambitious but realistic number i
think that so i went out with this guy
the other day
and he's a um no i'll i'll name drop you
look out can i name drop i went out with
lance armstrong i got dinner with lance
dude you weren't gonna say that you were
just going to say i went out with this
guy
the other day yeah well yeah amazing
i i i i ha the reason i'm saying that is
like it come from a reputable source
uh and he had this uh guy who worked at
adidas and nike with them this like huge
rip guy who was like he's probably
55 or so and he was telling me that
there's a direct correlation between
lean muscle mass
and age so like longevity
so the people who have more muscle at an
older age
are more likely to live longer and so
that was like a realization to me so
uh anyway that was uh so two for one you
get to be jacked now and live forever
yeah um but um
wait what were we talking about oh yeah
but
i do but so we just did this little
thing let's get back into it i
got a card an email from my aunt my aunt
debbie who's
in her 50s called i forget what it was
called but it was american greetings was
the name of the company
or the main i whenever i get like one of
these things i scroll straight to the
bottom and it says like the name of the
brand but then it says like copyright
american greeting right
the like terms and conditions part yeah
i'm like all right that's the good stuff
so i always like
wikipedia um and it was this company
it's a greeting card company that just
closed
can i pause you one second that thing
you just said that this podcast has like
rewired my brain where that's all i do
now i'm like
oh cool this thing is in my life who's
behind this how much do they make what's
the company what's the backstory is
there
an epic founder behind this i was at the
dentist and he's showing me an x-ray of
my teeth yesterday
and instead of looking at he's like
pointing out something in my teeth he's
like oh yeah
who makes that machine i'm looking at
the name of the software in the top left
corner it's like vm
you know vm imaging and i'm like i'm
like hey can you hand me my phone real
quick i need to just
i need to write this down i'm gonna go
look up this company i bet it makes like
billions of dollars doing this x-ray
software for dentists office
or like he was like scraping my tooth
with some tool
and i was just thinking why isn't there
like better divide this is the same
scraper they've been using since like i
was 10. uh
who if every dentist is buying these
things these things can't cost
they have to cost a lot of money who's
what's the company that makes these
little devices and are they innovating
why not you know blah blah blah so my
brain has been like
i have like this chip in my brain now
that that has to get to the root source
of every product i feel which is what
you whenever i
sent you a birthday card well when i see
a building like a huge warehouse
if that where like if it's a massive
warehouse and there's a sign on it i
always look up
what's the story of that right i always
do that so yeah
i was thinking like you know people are
excited about ar or like when google
glass came out
and they're like oh it's great you'll be
able to read your email or you'll be
able to like
see directions you know like the map
will be in front of your eyes
and i was like the killer app of this is
i just look at somebody and it tells me
who they are
like i can just like you know like when
you you stalk someone you see someone
interesting you like
try to look them up you find their
instagram you see what their life's all
about
i think it's gonna be amazing when we
just have contacts or glasses and i
could just look at you it'll be like
sampar ceo of the hustle
blah blah your last two tweets next to
your face floating above you
you have no idea that i just have like
well there's also interrogated you
there's also practical stuff
me and sarah were walking on the street
the other day and sarah saw a guy with
college shirt and she's like i think we
know that person
but i can't tell because all white guys
with collared shirts look look the same
to me
there's some practical there's some
practical implications
dude when i was a kid and i would use my
fake id
i had a fake id and the guy was a white
dude but he had like a shaved head
and it was like he had clearly had black
hair but if you go to the indian
or the black stores with like a black
color like a different
a clerk of a different race they all
thought that like always
looks just like you so the joke was you
have to go to a like a person who's not
white
because they all think we look exactly
the same
did you ever do that when you're a kid
like you go to like you got to go to the
white collar
i didn't realize that hack um but that
makes perfect sense to me yeah do you
think all white people look alike
uh no not all white people look alike
but definitely like you know
john jeff and jacob you know i might mix
them up from time to
yeah in time same way that you know i
look like you know
i'm sorry to everybody you know what i
mean like
yeah but we were talking about american
greetings american greetings
and the reason i bring this up huge
company and it's just crazy that this
[__] still exists
um but i guess it's not that crazy it's
funny just to explain in simple terms
they do e-cards
so you can send it to somebody 20 a year
yeah 20
year membership and uh they do above a
billion dollars in revenue they own
multiple smaller brands so they own like
jackie lawson have you ever heard of
jackie lawson by the way
no you should google this name so jackie
lawson go look at her website
and uh like welcome to 1982
so just i i mean whoever's doing the
video on this you've got to pull up the
job
literally okay so that the profile photo
looks like you know some bootleg carmen
san diego
and then it says jackie lawson and then
like there's like there's like a mouse
like a computer mouse is like like part
of the n
because probably like when she invented
this it was like new to be like
on the computer sending cards to people
and uh
this thing is incredibly popular people
love jackie lawson cards
she's like a really well-known solder
company i think to american greetings
and um i ran a company for a period of
time maybe
a year or two it's called
birthdayalarm.com
by the way i didn't start this company
but the company's kind of remarkable
i'll break it down so
um michael and xochi birch were the
investors in my previous company this
was their first
win so michael is a programmer at an
insurance company he's like
ah this is boring wants to go do a
startup he comes up with this big idea
to do
a self-updating address book meaning
like what if you had a contact list
that was like dynamic so i'm in your
address book if i ever move
i can just change my address or my my
email address or whatever
and it'll automatically update in
everyone's contact list uh
you know dynamically so you have this
idea of this um
you build this product it's really
complicated it's not really going
anywhere
but he adds one feature to the address
book which is uh
birthday what's your birthday and um
which is ironically the thing that
doesn't change
you don't need a dynamic address book to
do that but he started sending a
reminder so
like a little reminder would come out
like i should have got a reminder
yesterday that said hey it's sam's
birthday today wish him happy birthday
and um and this was before facebook so
this is actually an incredible you
incredibly useful thing
so people used to email him being like
hey um
thanks so much for that birthday
reminder i would have totally forgot my
aunt's birthday you know you saved me on
that one
or you know i looked like husband of the
year because of that birthday reminder
and um so he's like [__] nobody likes my
thing but they just like this one
feature so he makes that the product so
he goes he makes it
birthdayalarm.com and all it does is it
reminds you of your friends and family's
birthday
and um immediately the the site starts
to like do
a little bit better but not like not
gangbusters yet so he says okay
well how does this product work i should
be able to email all my
friends and family and say hey add your
birthday to my my
birthday alarm calendar and um
and then he does he at the time there
was no term for viral marketing
but he's like i don't have a budget to
do you know i quit my job to go
try to make it big in the startup world
so i don't have a marketing budget so i
need one user to recruit another
so here's what i'll do when i email all
my friends and families to add their
birthday to mine
and they go type in june 15th then it'll
say do you want to save sean's birthday
and your calendar
and they're like oh yeah sure why not
you know tit for tat he just asked for
mine i'll take his
and then it says cool your birth your
calendar has one birthday in it
who else's birthday do you want to know
send this to your friends and family
so that became the viral loop and all of
a sudden he started getting tens of
thousands of members
still a free product but tens of
thousands of users at the time to him
felt like
a million dollars it was like oh my god
i've actually made something that's
growing
and then he's like all right how do i
make this even better so he's just
he went all in on this virality piece he
didn't try to figure out the business
model
and he's like how do i make this even
more viral and so he's like well
today there's still all these steps
involved i gotta type in each person's
email address
i have to figure out what to write so he
starts one by one
changing these pieces he's like oh
instead of you having to think what to
write
i'll write it for you just copy paste
this right here's a copy button
to copy this into your email a client
and then he's like could i just
send this to their whole email address
book and at the time nobody was really
doing this
and so he wrote one of the first
scrapers for hotmail
where he where you could just log into
your hotmail and he's like great i
imported all your contacts
just hit send and it'll send to all of
them and um
he's like dude this is kind of crazy
like he's like for sure hotmail is going
to shut this down in 10 days
but uh whatever 10 days of growth let's
do it
and so immediately he wakes up next
morning and there's like 100 000 members
and it just keeps growing exponentially
after that and
you know here we are he started that
website in 2001 so 20 years later
you could still do that thing in hotmail
at gmail where you import your address
book
they never were able to like fully shut
it down and so he's like
that hack that i thought would last 10
days lasted 20 years
and the site started growing
exponentially so now it has you know
it's had over
i don't know maybe a hundred million
members at this point um
add their birthdays making like five
million dollars a year every single year
so at that point it's free now what
happens is
his buddy morgan um he who's like a
a friend of his sends them a link to uh
i don't know what it was it was either
jackie lawson
american greetings blue mountain one of
these websites he goes dude
you should do e-cards um i made a i made
an e-card website you should add e-cards
that could be the business model sell
birthday cards right don't just remind
them of the birthday let them wish them
a happy birthday
turns that on immediately starts making
ten thousand dollars a day or whatever
numbers are not exact in fact we
re-released his episodes you can go
listen
to the exacts but basically starts
making money that business with just
like
pretty bare bones so it was him working
on his wife working on it
you know his sister-in-law did the books
and there was like you know cousin did
customer support
it ran like that for a number of years
and just had like you know outsourced
people making ecards
and it was making at its peak four or
five million dollars a year
of revenue with most of that being
profit like maybe 80
profit at that time and it ran like that
for
a number of years he used that to
self-fund his next startup
a social network called bebo and then
because he self-funded it with birthday
alarm
when he sold bibo for 850 million
dollars
the husband and wife duo they owned like
70 plus of the company because he had
self-funded it using it this using this
e-card website
and so when i went to go run his idea
lab that was still the cash cow that was
paying for that fancy office you saw
all those silicon valley engineers most
of it was because birthday alarm was
still cranking
two million dollars a year of profit
even though nobody was working on it and
there had been no updates for like
multiple years at that point
and so then i took it and we tried to
like turn it around and make it grow
again and so
it started to grow again um you know
after we worked on it but
because of that i looked into jackie
lawson and american greetings and jib
jab and
all these different companies and this
space is actually pretty big yeah well
that's why i brought this up because i
knew i would get a story out of you like
that
there's also one other company that
somebody who listens to the podcast
had told us i'll give them a shout have
you seen this app called
givingly no so it's a
it's a new age version of this same idea
so giving me what they do
what they make easy is that they're like
not just good looking cards
but a gift card to like any service so
uh
like it was my trainer's birthday i
wanted to get him something i had
forgotten to give him a gift
and so i sent him a givingly which was
like a beautiful little e-card i made on
my phone
in like you know five minutes and then i
was able to attach like 100
door dash pass to it so it's like oh
dinner tonight's on me
is what i sent him and um and so it was
like so easy to send a gift
and a gift card and i was like oh this
is actually kind of interesting and so i
talked to the founders and their stats
are
honestly pretty impressive people send a
ton of these and the
way that they grew is a little
unconventional they grew
as a snapchat mini app which like you
kind of don't hear anyone talking about
like do you ever hear about snapchat
minis
no i don't even know what that is they
released this like app platform called
minis
and like you never really hear anybody
talking about it and then when they
showed me their numbers i'm like dude
where are you getting like
hundreds of thousands of users and
they're like oh snapchat like
people on snapchat just send little
cards back and forth to each other all
the time we're the number one mini
and it's like what and so i went and
looked in the little mini store and sure
enough they were like one or two
uh at the time so i thought that was
kind of interesting and it made me think
oh i should do a deep dive into minis
and see what else is actually working
here
that's that's fascinating and that's
we've talked about this like idea of
like you need distribution first and if
you have that you have everything and
like
that's why i like chrome plugins that's
why i like uh wordpress plugins i didn't
even know about minis
yeah and you know i don't know if you
need it first there is definitely like
a case for that other people will say no
you need a product people love and
other people say no you need a great
team and like the way i think about it
is
this guy near ayal who i think also
listens podcast he wrote this book
called hooked
and oh he's a listener that's cool i've
i've read that book
yeah and so he uh it's awesome book and
so he he had told me this once in my
office he goes
uh every business is like a three-legged
stool you have
growth you have engagement and you have
monetization gem and he's like
uh you know when you start your startup
you have none you just have like you
know a stool with no legs
and then you need to get your first leg
on there it can be growth or it can be
engagement like a sticky product that
people love um
he's like a good startup will have two
and if you have two you have a pretty
good shot of figuring out the third
the problem is there's a whole bunch of
people here with one-legged stools uh
trying to go raise money
and uh i thought that was so spot-on and
so then when i looked at companies i
just
thought to myself oh do they have all
three legs figured out
two of the three i'm okay with one of
the three i'm gonna wait
dude i dig it i and i completely agree
with that um
we have like a ton of ideas here i'm i'm
really excited can i tell you something
really quick though that i learned
yeah so do you remember is it called pro
republic
what was that article that got released
with rich people i think pro republic
was the name it was like the billionaire
taxes i didn't read it by the way so
i don't know you don't have to have read
it but there
okay so there's something going i didn't
read it either but it's not important
because it's
the general topic of this of
like how rich people pay little taxes
and they do that by
basically and like i don't know how to
bring this up without sounding like a
total douche but when you make little
money like
you get access to loans that are like
1.5 percent or 1.2
or whatever it is it's it's based off of
like a lot of times they'll be watching
people get the most free [__]
whether it's or cheap capital or cheap
anything yeah
basically like when you sign up for like
a big bank you get a line of credit
like i think it's 75 of your of the
amount of money you have in there
uh at like a one percent rate or it's
like based off the london bond exchange
and i was curious about this but
basically a lot of folks like elon
and just most people who are wealthy or
a lot of people who are wealthy
they take loans and that's what they use
to live on
but in my head i'm like but you still
gotta pay that back so how are they
doing that
and i went and talked to some bankers
and you know how this like do you know
what the expectation is here
the expectation is that you actually
live on those loans forever forever yeah
and your estate pays it when you die
is that crazy is that a crazy thing to
think about i kept thinking like
but how does the bank get their money
back and it's like oh no no like we
expect
that it's going to be an outstanding
loan for like 50 years and we're just
going to keep loaning and loaning and
loaning
and then when they die they're not
trying to make their money off you the
wealthy person they're trying to take
all of your millions and millions of
dollars and lend it out to other people
who are gonna pay higher rates
so they're like okay we need to lend
money where do we get the money let's
get the money from rich people how do we
get the money from rich people we
offer them amazing terms okay then how
do we make money well we're going to
take that money
and we're going to lend it to people who
don't have as much and we're going to
charge them more
right kind of sounds screwed up when you
say it but that's the business model
here i believe
yeah it's just like something that i
didn't understand i feel like
if i'm wrong i might be wrong because
i'm not a banker nor am i a bank nor
have i thought about this stuff
it's just weird i just thought that was
weird and that was totally like that was
one of those things where it's like
well it's funny why this is how the
world works i was like i didn't know
that i'm just like well it's funny
because like
you're like oh um you're the ceo how
much do you make oh wow this ceo came
out and said he's taking a one dollar
salary for the year
what a great guy he's like no obviously
that that just means he doesn't make his
money off his salary he makes it off
something else
okay he's getting stuck okay great wow
he's getting all the stock stocks going
up you must pay a ton in taxes
no no he he doesn't why is that well he
doesn't sell the stock
so he doesn't realize any gain okay then
how does he pay for like that jet oh
because he just
like len he gets a big loan or line of
credit
off of his stock as collateral and so
wait
so he lives for free off that loan yeah
yeah he does he just has to pay you know
one percent or two percent or three
percent interest oh wow that seems
pretty good
okay even better let's say he takes that
money and uses it to invest
now that interest payment is also tax
deductible so it's like just gets like
kind of crazy how
the advantages sort of stack up against
each other it was just he bought real
estate great
now he's gonna take this huge
depreciation you know uh
on on the real estate he bought and then
if he sells it for a gain he's gonna
1031 exchange it into another real
estate property
and pay no gains it's pretty amazing i
felt like
um when i learned this i felt like i was
sitting like i went to a fancy dinner
table
for the first time they finally showed
me like that small fork is meant for
like taking crab meat out of the claw i
was like
oh that's that's for oh
like well goddamn that's the kid's fork
yeah i was like
that was the little people i don't know
what that is anyway i
that was like it's just like hit me in
the head i'm like duh so that was the so
i had a call with a tax guy a tech
strategist
um i'm paying for this like tax
strategist because i'm like okay where
did you figure this stuff out
my brother-in-law had found somebody
through a thing he and he saved him a
bunch of money and
he was telling me about it i was like i
gotta talk to this guy so i talked to
him it's got jeff
and um he's like okay you know so what
are your goals here you know and i was
like
i want to learn what the rich people do
to pay less taxes
and then you know decide or try to do
some of those things if they apply to me
and he's like okay and i was like so
walk me through here like
if i make this much money in a year
i'm just doing this i'm just writing
this huge tax bill tax check you know
every year
what do they do where they don't have to
do that and he was like just kind of
like amused at my line of questioning
but in the end he was like super helpful
he really like kind of outlined
all the things and then at the end i was
like all right
how does attorney-client privilege work
here i was like let's just say i tell
you that
you know this uh this part of my house
that's my home office deduction
sometimes i nap there and like also i
store my dog stuff there right like this
unrelated to my office um i said how
honest can i be with you
and he goes you can be totally honest
and i recommend you do
but there's no attorney like rivers i
can be subpoenaed he goes
i'm not to do anything wrong because i
don't have to you're okay great
you basically just need to ask for like
red light green light yellow light like
now he'll be like they'll be like yeah
so like are you active or passive on
that i'm like
suppose i was active what would the
number be at the end and then suppose i
was passive and then i will give you my
answer
by the end of this and he's like reading
between the lines of like oh okay i
understand
we haven't even actually gotten into any
of my stuff but i wanted to ask all the
questions up front to him about like
uh like i i'm more fascinated with how
the tax thing works i don't even have
like a very complicated setup there's
not really anything i could do
uh because i'm not like elon i don't
have this like complicated structure and
all these shares i can borrow against in
that same structure
but i'm more i'm paying this guy to tell
me what other rich people do
and uh i'm fine with that i think that's
a great trade
do you want to talk about you want to go
uh i've got one idea
so so i i i well uh uh
you want to do mine first i mean i can
give you a summary then we can get into
it later
yeah do yours okay do you know who paul
singh is
i never met him but i've heard about him
and my buddy is his business partner
great so paul a baby bump bump boxes
bump box so yeah sorry so you'll
actually know more about this than i do
so i reached out to paul because uh i
don't even know how i contacted him but
paul singh
is a guy who started this thing called
500 startups they're not really around
too much anymore
but yeah they didn't start it right did
he start it dave mcclure
yeah maybe he didn't start it but he was
like there at the beginning and so
uh yeah i i don't know if he helped
start maybe it's the right word and he
was just he was a guy there
um he helped make it popular and somehow
he uh started traveling in an rv that
was his shtick was like i
he actually left san francisco before
it's cool he goes i just want to travel
in an rv
and years and years and years ago he
started a coasting company like a web
hosting company and he wouldn't talk to
me about it too much because it's kind
of private
but he's like basically i make millions
of dollars a year from cash flow from
that
and i invest a large amount into
privately held companies both brick and
mortar and tech startups every single
year
and i would travel just to meet new
potential investments and at one point i
met these folks who had this thing
called
bump box it wasn't very popular and so
it sounds like you know the people from
bump box right yeah i know it's super
well
oh well then you probably know a lot
more than i do but let me tell you what
i know so he met these folks and he
bought into it
um he didn't start it and he didn't buy
it outright but i think he bought into
it so for like two or three hundred
thousand dollars something like that
he bought a portion i don't know how
much it was but basically the whole
shtick was
we know uh statistically like where you
should be in your pregnancy and like
the the feelings that you're gonna have
and the products that you're gonna need
um and so we sell you a monthly box for
fifty dollars
well let me simplify that part i think
it's more like when you get pregnant
especially for the first time
there's like all these new things
happening inside your body outside your
body you're trying to figure stuff out
and there's like a million things that
you're supposed to buy and get to do
but you don't know what they are and
even if you know what they are
you don't know which product to buy
because you want to buy the one that's
like
safe but also effective but also
whatever into a lot of reading reviews
trying products and so what bumbox did
which is pretty genius was they just
said look
we're gonna find the best products for
every phase of your pregnancy first
trimester second trimester third and
then post
and we're going to package it up into a
subscription box so you're just
it's just going to show up on your
doorstep you don't even have to think
and worry about the stuff anymore
and so paul came in and he's like yeah
they're doing you guys are this is okay
it's pretty good
i think we could think of just a tad bit
bigger and we could turbo charge this
and so now their vision is basically
from conception to like 18 19 20 years
old
a mother is handling lots of different
stuff
and we want to be the place that she
turns to for
a variety of different like needs to
care for her kids right and the
company's pretty interesting
it's like 40 million dollars in sales
his goal is to grow the company
2x every single year and of that 40
million in revenue 60
is from subscription boxes and 30 is
from this
30 to 40 is this other stuff and paul
came into this business
and he goes these boxes are great but
let's just make more and more
and more stuff for this person so let's
figure out everything the mom needs and
let's just make it
and so now 30 or 40 of their business
comes from medical equipment which i
don't even know what that means whatever
i don't know what they sell so like i
don't know if they're selling this yet
we might have to take this out i don't
know if it's out yet but like for
example
uh a breast pump so when you when when
you're breastfeeding
you're gonna pump in between feeds or
whatever and
uh insurance covers it and so you know
these things are expensive
devices that you need medical devices
that the doctor sort of gives you
that you'll use for the first year or so
of your pregnancy
after birth and the other stuff they
sell is they'll figure out that you want
this
and they're going to call you and one of
their insurance agents are going to call
you and say
here's the 50 best types of insurance
companies that you should check out
if you want to buy this breast pump or
whatever they're it's all covered by
insurance and then they make a cut off
that lead
so kind of an interesting company um
that i wanted to talk about and i wanted
to talk about because
there's a few things going on here first
this is a guy who has
made a lot of money angel investing in
tech companies and he told me
i never want to raise money i want to
own as much as this business as i can
and we can either distribute profits to
ourselves and our employees or we could
sell for a [__] load of money
and b i just think that it's kind of
interesting it's not like it's
it's out of my world that you know i
don't have kids i'm not a woman uh it's
kind of interesting what do you know
about this
um so leland who's the uh the
the founder and hit leona's wife i don't
remember my name top of my head but
they started this thing they're amazing
he's been so helpful to me
in e-commerce um he really knows his
[__]
and just awesome guy i think they're
based in illinois or something like that
and uh you know super super nice in the
midwest built this company out
it's kind of a great company and i think
subscription is really hard to do but
when you do it
it's fantastic and i think they've done
a pretty good job of actually
actually pulling it off and the way he
says that he's like we're not a box
company we're a mom acquisition machine
and i'm like that's absolutely right and
that's why they think bigger than just
what what's one product we could sell
them okay box might be the first
what's the second what's the third
what's the fourth because we're just
gonna acquire moms
um at an insane insanely good rate and
be able to offer them products that
they're going to need for you know the
period of their uh
of their child you know child care time
and i said to paul i go you know like
this is great but you are doing a lot of
stuff that
i think is a bad idea but it's a great
idea i mean clearly you're making
it work which is you are not just
stan you're not focusing exactly you're
you're focusing on the mother category
but you're launching loads of different
stuff and he goes yeah that's actually
our goal
and the reason we're doing that is uh
our our whole
unique strategy is that we're gonna move
quickly but he's like when you think
about it
a hundred years ago at some board
meeting the guys at p e or kellogg or
whatever it is
the big conglomerates nowadays they go
you know like look we could
start building you could start selling
more soap or we could just buy
all the soap and then buy all the razors
and just buy everything
that like you possibly use in your home
and own the whole category as opposed to
just
focusing on this one thing and even
though tech focuses
on this one thing let's just do the
opposite and say you know why can't we
build a family of companies and i
thought that was pretty cool it broke my
frame
it's a little different than what i've
heard um or what i would have done and i
think it's neat to see something that's
the opposite of what i like
i think they did focus on getting boxes
core to work for a number of years right
that's not new obviously
yeah so so you you buy yourself the
right
to try a bunch of new things by getting
your core to work really really well
and get to scale so i think they did
that part they weren't doing i don't
think five different things
before the other thing is like this idea
is so simple
and but when you talk to leland you're
like oh you're like a
badass operator like he's in the
nitty-gritty he's like oh yeah
and facebook ads i can put i can copy
paste this over here and if i do that
it's like it's just a little bit better
the platform doesn't even really support
it but i can do it manually this way or
like
you know um they'll use it you know like
they're when they're marketing to people
they're
like yeah we actually call i don't know
if you've ever heard of this have you
heard of like ringless voicemail
no this is like this marketing tactic
that he's like oh yeah we call our
customers i was like
don't people hate getting calls he's
like oh it's not a call it goes straight
to voicemail
i was like what is it yeah there's a way
to call somebody that goes straight to
voicemail you leave a message
so it's a great way to like that's
staying in the email inbox and you're
buried under 5000 of their emails
the person might get one or two
voicemails a day and one of them can be
from us
and people like hearing from us and they
hear a voice of a human being talking to
them
i'm like he's just doing a thousand of
those small
operational wins every year
and i'm like oh that's why you win
because this is a simple idea that i
think nine out of ten entrepreneurs who
tried this same exact idea
would have failed same idea a portion of
it if
he's a powerhouse he just needs some
help early on i think they needed some
capital and i think they
met paul pretty impressed by him and i
think he's been a good kind of partner
for them
but you know if you if you offered them
a deal now i don't think they would take
it right because
he's in a different position now than
when it's just like
i mean he started the company him and
his wife were like i think they were
like at a conference or something like
that and they were just like walking it
was like
you know like the parking lot or the
water the hot dog stands like you know
far away because everything's even
convenient at an event
and while they were walking there they
basically like had this idea they're
like screw it why don't we do this like
let's start a business
why don't we just go for it and they
just like kind of decided to do it and
so
you know at that point you're really
green you don't know anything and then
now he knows obviously a lot because
he's been doing this for i don't know
whatever seven years or something have
you heard
of i'm making a quick pivot have you
heard of this thing called the
anti-galloway index
i don't know if it's a real thing i know
that a lot of people basically
make fun of scott galloway for being
absolutely wrong about all his
investment advice and predictions
so there's this guy someone turned it
into an actual festival
no no no um so there's this guy named
scott galloway scott galloway i've had
lunch with him he's been nothing but
nice to me but
a lot of people dislike him because he
makes some crazy statements
he's um they tease him for being real
woke he
makes these predictions where he puts
like the my the winners and losers of
each year and he makes these really bold
predictions
yeah and a lot of people attack and a
lot of people in general
make fun of them because his predictions
i mean i'm sure some of them are right
but like
a lot of them are wrong like really
wrong massively wrong
like one time he said that macy's is
gonna crush amazon
and that's just an example and some
[__]
who i love made a thing called the
anti-galloway index
and if you so basically if you would
have done the opposite of everything he
said
since 2019 uh tech companies that
professor galloway has predicted would
fail have outperformed the s p
500 by a whopping 61 percent
no no they've outperformed as you've
heard and have the
return itself is 61 percent
sorry you know during the time and you
know even if you it says even if you
exclude tesla which was one of his big
bets that he said was fail and
it took off and said even without that
one still 23 percent
uh return that's crazy isn't it this is
hilarious who made this let's give him a
shot i don't know
okay that's hilarious this is cool uh
yeah let's
so okay here's the idea by the way which
is um
is there i think there is there's some
new products that are coming out
that let anybody create a basket of
stocks that's like like for example
i think there's a company called doji
that's doing this doji
and what they do is uh you can go cr i
can go create the sean index
and it's five stocks that i'm investing
in and you can actually put your money
into my index and buy it buy those
stocks and then it'll show over time how
my index is performed
um and i can make the tech index and i
can make my like
high-risk high-reward index or whatever
that's my understanding i haven't used
the product but
my understanding is it's kind of like
that which i think is an awesome idea by
the way what do you think of that idea
yeah i mean
why can't you do that on um i i've
mentioned him before i think it's called
like
bull bull something there's that one uh
there's a one israeli robin hood uh
competitor and they've done this
it's called copy trader and you can
create weeble is that what it is
um and you could do this on that
platform i think it's sick i think it's
awesome
yeah it seems really cool i don't know
if i get some incentive by like sharing
my basket but that would be like a
really cool model where
essentially i get a small cut of the
assets that are invested into it
if we perform or something like that and
and then you can see like who's right
who's wrong and not just people who
cherry pick oh i invested in this one
thing and it's done great but they don't
tell you about the five losers they had
here it's like all on the record what
you what you
picked and then you know you can see
like the gallow index uh
i think it's amazing so you want to talk
about some of your ideas
uh yeah sure uh which one do you want to
do so
uh have you heard about this phantom
secure thing i thought this was pretty
sweet no
so um okay so there was a story the
other day about the fbi
had this huge crackdown on criminals and
i was like okay that's interesting tell
me about it
and so i was reading it and in there
they were talking about
this um the story okay so there was this
app
called phantom secure and phantom secure
was it was
marketed basically as a as an app that
you can use if you don't want
you know anybody to see what you're
writing here right so obviously
criminals are like hey that's
interesting i'd rather right there than
on gmail right where my stuff is stored
on a server somewhere and i can get
you know those those records can get
subpoenaed or whatever
and so phantom secure at its peak had
20 000 users um it would make 80 million
dollars
off those 20 000 users so just like math
because you would pay to use it right
because for you you're like this is a
business
tool for me if i'm a criminal uh i need
secure messaging
i'll pay for this and so they were
making four thousand dollars per user
and just for like comparison whatsapp
makes like two dollars per user so you
know four thousand dollars per user was
it's like an enterprise product for
criminals but why were they paying for
that versus like the other things like
telegram or whatever it is
because this was even more secure what
you were getting here
is you're not just getting an app you're
getting a phone
that has been wiped all the uh all the
other apps are gone
there's only a secure messaging app on
the phone that
secure messaging app will self-destruct
under certain conditions if you're like
you know arrested or you trigger it or
whatever somebody misses that mess up
the password three times
so it's a like it's a burner device
designed for
criminal communications cto gets
arrested um
the only way you could even get into the
app was through referral right so
so this thing existed they arrested the
guy and criminals were like oh [__] we
don't have this app anymore
so the fbi these i don't know the story
is like these two detectors were out to
lunch one day and they're like
why don't we create another phantom
secure but we own the thing we own the
bag channel so
they created this app called anon like
anonymous
and they put it on 12 000 phones it took
and
they let it be out there for 18 months
for criminals to use and start to trust
and refer other criminals onto it
and the whole time every message is
going to the fbi secure servers
but they just waited they just let the
thing spread like a virus all throughout
the criminal organizations and then they
just took
everybody down and i was like that is a
badass story
how did you find that props i don't know
i saw this story and i just clicked it
it's amazing
so do you think okay so i think that
i actually think this is amazing idea by
the way it sucks that people were using
it that way but i i think it's an
amazing idea kind of like
silk road is like an amazing idea where
it's like yeah like it's cool
to create like a marketplace where you
can sell anything but it's kind of
shitty
like i don't want to support anything
where like right now who are the people
that want a marketplace that'll sell
them
anything even different stuff than i can
sell on ebay
oh right you know drug dealers in it
like you know assassins it's like
weapons like i'm not like in favor of
actually everything
you know i'm not actually a true
libertarian because i do think that like
some stuff should be illegal right right
um but i am incredibly bullish on things
like what's it called the so there's
duckduckgo do you see duckduckgo
they just took took a bunch of funding i
didn't see that no
yeah they sold 100 million dollars worth
of um
secondary shares and they're doing over
100 million in revenue right and then
also do you know proton
is it called protonmail right the the
laughing
so the funny thing is all these ideas i
remember hearing about like duckduckgo
six years ago i remember reading about
it being like oh that's kind of weird
like i thought it was like huge does
anyone care
like do people really care oh no it
doesn't seem like they care
move on protonmail signal all these apps
and then they were right their core
insight which is that people are gonna
care about privacy
people are gonna care about not being
tracked by big tech companies not being
advertised to
and they're going to care about not
having their all their messages
stored forever in a way that could get
leaked or hacked and uh you know you get
cancelled or you get your business
secrets you know outed like sony did
right and so all those ended up being
true
and at the time and for years they
looked like
non-winners people weren't really using
them at the time i totally agree i
thought it was stupid i'm like doctor go
what are you talking about now i
uh it's my it's my it's what i use
you use that as your default uh uh i use
it often and i'm starting to use that as
default yeah
and um do you use brave because brave is
the new one that i think fits into this
category
break brown no i haven't yet because
switching from chrome is shockingly
challenging
right but switching from anything
switching from mail messaging they're
all
they're all google's a bit easier is it
why
like switching my search thing yeah
oh i mean i could probably get good
results on bing or google i mean i i
i i'm just really trying to go to the
wikipedia or quora or facebook or
twitter
right i'm pretty i'm pretty sure that uh
private browsing
basically you know like a brave brave or
a brave like
company five years from now we're gonna
look at it and it's gonna be just like
duckduckgo
or signal um in that like it just takes
over slowly but surely
i agree and i think that ten years from
now we're gonna say like
i can't believe you used to use x y and
z and you would just do that
like that's shocking to me right you
used to just give up your location to
to anybody to be advertised to right you
used to like alexa right you used to
just have like a hot mic
on in your house all the time right so
those are going to seem
like strange strangers
the other day if you didn't listen we
had this guy named mike maples on and he
was kind of a genius and he was
he talked about inflections and he's
like what i i invest in early stage
stuff
and it's pretty impossible to predict
what's going to be big so i try to
use some frameworks and i just basically
think like you know what
interesting things what interesting
inflections are going to happen in 10
years that's going to make x y and z
possible but it's not possible right now
and i'm going to try and get into it so
like for example
uh uber what made it possible was
everyone started having
really great phones that had gps's in it
without those gps's it would have been
very challenging to do this
right and one of those inflections that
i believe to be true and i'm trying to
put my money where my mouth is and
invest stuff like it is this privacy
thing
i believe that that i believe that to be
true i believe that's going to be a big
thing coming up i don't know who's going
to win or what the
uh what the end result will look like
but i believe
right right you know what to look for
and you know what's going to look
strange now right we talked about
guardian that app on your phone that
like it's like a
auto vpn for for your mobile apps brave
browser i think fits into that
you know when mike maples was on he said
something really fast
that i thought was actually super
insightful that we didn't really go into
he goes
he goes every like kind of era of tech
um the old valuable thing becomes like
completely commoditized and there
becomes a new valuable thing so what
does that mean so he goes
you know back when it was like at first
you were selling pcs
and all the money to be made was in the
hardware and then
you had like microsoft and others
basically come up and they're like
cool ibm you be the hardware we're gonna
be the software
and then like all the money shifted from
being made into hardware to the hardware
became completely commoditized and all
the money was made
in software applications and then it was
like oh software applications are
you know like where all the money's made
and then people started making services
like google and facebook
it's like wait it's a free software
application so then how do you make
money it's like
because data data's the valuable thing
you don't realize that right microsoft
doesn't realize that they're going to
charge you for the software we're going
to give away free software
but we're going to make all the money on
the data and it's like okay great
and the shift that's happening now is
that data is the thing that makes money
we're gonna make our data open open
source we're gonna make our blockchain
open anybody can build on top of it
and uh we're gonna go open data so then
where's all the money to be made
and then you have like kind of like a
new answer that comes after that
and so i thought that was like such a
spot-on
observation and it's like that's how you
observe
that's how the next you know 100 billion
500 billion dollar company looks nothing
like the last one if you're just looking
to match
what's the next microsoft you're never
going to think it's facebook this
college social network that's free
right you're never gonna think it's
google the search engine that's free
you're gonna think it's supposed to look
more like
more like microsoft this like enterprise
paid software thing
but no it keeps switching because they
they react to it in that way
and so like that's why you know i got
kind of made fun of when i was talking
about bitcloud
but big cloud i think is an example of
this where they took
the most valuable part of facebook and
twitter which is
the social graph and the data that's uh
that's underneath it
and they were like nope that's going to
be freely available anybody can take our
data you can make a better version of
big cloud
you can like you can make a new skin
make a new client you can make a fork
off this
the data is all open open chain which
facebook would never give you access to
their database that shows you every
person their photos and their friends
you can never get access like that it's
their most prized possession
and big cloud basically says that's now
free instead we're going to make our
money on
these crater coins right a different
method i think that you've said a lot of
amazing stuff for the past two years i
think this little rant right here
might be the most like not valuable in
the sense of like whenever you talk
about like fluffy [__] that's
useful of like i need to have confidence
yeah like that is useful i call it
fluffy but it's incredibly useful
i think what you just said right there
actually might be one of the most
valuable rants in terms of just money
that you've ever said i think that um
i think that i do not have the ability
to build
pretty much any of the things that
you're discussing i don't you might
have the ability but i certainly don't i
don't think you do either but
i think that if you are listening to
this and you think you have the ability
to do some of this some of this stuff i
think like there you we've
very clearly just said a thesis of what
like the world's gonna be like in 10
years and i would bet my own personal
money that that actually is going to be
true and i think
it's going to be um not just true little
but like true
a significant amount right and there's
not just
one trend happening at once right like i
remember talking to alex to the founder
of calm
and he just believed that like
mindfulness and being and you know calm
and meditation was going to become a
bigger thing
and there was multiple years where it
was not getting it was not growing very
fast
because it wasn't a thing and then sure
enough people started to feel really
fatigued with technology they started to
feel really busy and constantly
on and the mobile phone was too much and
then wow
there's this app that like is actually
designed not for me to constantly use it
and check it keep checking the
notifications over and over and over
again
this app is to calm me down and
mindfulness and mental health became a
thing
and it's like yeah mental health became
a thing and he was prepared he was ready
with
a solution for that that he had been
baking for years
yeah so i i think it's bullish or
bullish i think it's amazing i think
it's gonna be a thing you want to do a
couple more you want to do this
chick-fil-a thing
so i read this i read this blog post
this article that the chick-fil-a
tech team put out and um if i'm not the
biggest chick-fil-a customer i'm
top five easily in the country so uh you
know so anything chick-fil-a i'm gonna
read
and what they were talking about was
like chick-fil-a using ai machine
learning blah blah and i was like oh let
me see what this is some [__]
and i started reading it it was actually
pretty interesting first of all 90 of it
was just over my head
but i thought it was pretty fascinating
what they were saying well first two
things
they kind of like they put their stake
in the ground which i appreciate they go
chick-fil-a is you know a restaurant
that's sort of different than others
we're only open six days a week but we
do more sales than people that are open
seven days a week
i was like baller like strive to be
chick-fil-a you know like
i want to be the chick-fil-a i want to
work less and make more uh than somebody
who's working more
and the you know the other thing i
thought about was like a lot of people
hate chick-fil-a because they're like
kind of like overly christian and like
have like
like anti-gay marriage and stuff like
that um and i'm like oh that sucks but
like this chicken is so good i'm gonna
eat here
you know like the chicken wins and then
what i would always say it's like
i can like r kelly's voice but not like
him
like i can admit that i believe i could
fly is like a banger
and also say he's a horrible human being
also you're not invited to my daughter's
birthday party yeah like i could do hope
it is possible to do both and so with
chick-fil-a it's like i want to stuff my
mouth with chicken
and then be like you guys you guys are
wrong you know like that's how i want to
be
so anyways i'm i'm like you want to be
like chick-fil-a a product so good
that you can actually be batshit crazy
or even offensive
and still the person who disagrees with
you they need your product it's that
good it's must-have so
then they were talking about their tech
and they were like well our stores when
we designed them
we thought they were only going to
handle like let's say just for
simplicity say 100 orders
100 customers a day or whatever but
the actual usage the demand is so high
for chick-fil-a that we get
three times more output than the store
was designed for
and he's like so how do we do that right
once you design the store it's kind of
it's already built you can't really go
back and change it
so we've had to use technology to get 3x
the output that the thing was designed
to do
it goes so the first thing we tried to
do was
can we like predict demand better right
so if you want to pump orders out faster
instead of waiting until after the order
happens i should
i should just say hey there's always a
lunch rush at noon so i'm going to throw
a bunch of fries in
and i'm just gonna know that i get this
much demand he goes but the problem is
there's too many variables you know a
soccer game ends nearby you get a rush
of customers
the weather changes and that causes a
dip in customers
um you know there's too much traffic on
the highway that's caused the dip so
it's too unpredictable you can't just
say
fridays at noon are always gonna have
this much demand
um too many external variables but he
goes so what we did do instead
was we put like hundreds of sensors
inside of a store
so that in real time i'm basically
taking the you know like
the order as the person's typing it into
the to the machine
and that's that's uh being matched with
a sensor that
tells us how active the fry machine is
and then it gives a signal to the worker
to basically like hey dude put more
fries in there's going to be more demand
or whatever right like
they're taking all these signals and how
many people are in the drive-through
times this times that and
basically making predictions of what do
they need to make so that they can get
that extra
20 of orders done per hour for
throughput and so i thought this was
kind of interesting and i don't even
fully understand the model and i'm kind
of like
i'm kind of like um what's like it's not
like mansplaining i'm like dumbsplaining
like
the thing i just said is not actually
what they do but it's the essence of
what they do
uh which is they take a whole they have
a hundred hundred like sort of smart
devices
like what this whole podcast is is we
just said like
they just it just it just bump boxes all
they do is they just sell [__] that like
i mean need that's all right
they're not like expert at facebook ads
or experts at like deal making for like
supply chain stuff i mean
they just do that right so so
the point is there's like 100 smart
devices in the chick-fil-a that are
feeding into a machine learning
algorithm to put something out there so
that a front-line worker who makes i
don't know
16 an hour is able to be more effective
and they're able to get more source
more sales per square foot and so i
started thinking like first of all
i had no idea that like kind of
old-school companies like chick-fil-a
are that deep into like adding
technology into their stores and their
services
and it made me think two for two ideas
the first is
those people should spin the engineers
working on that should spin out of
chick-fil-a
and then go offer this as a service to
every other restaurant is basically like
hey
chick-fil-a spent 50 million dollars
over the last five years
developing the technology to make their
store smarter um
so we generalized it and it's a product
for you right that's my my old export
framework they should export this idea
from chick-fil-a
and make it available to any any
restaurant chain
so that's like the first idea the second
idea is
what are the companies that are like
mckinsey or like a consulting company
because i assume chick-fil-a when they
go out in the job market they're trying
to hire
machine learning and ai engineers i bet
they're finding it pretty hard to
compete with like google and facebook
and
open ai and all these other companies
like what what great engineer is going
to work for chick-fil-a right like i
think you'd be surprised
um you know who who crushed it with um
tech stuff or relatively speaking was
walmart um walmart had this amazing
thing called the walmart innovation lab
in silicon valley
yep it was pretty sick and i went to um
i was reading the other day about the
most beloved brands amongst young people
and it's like uh target it's like vans
starbucks one other one and like the
number one
most loved brand is chick-fil-a right
so fair enough graduate
is going to work for chick-fil-a and
they're cutting against the grain but i
think most people are going to go
towards more traditional brands which
really told me
the way most companies are going to
solve this is not by having as much
in-house tech talent as consultants that
basically take
good tech talent but like hyper hyper
charge them to get them to go faster
and so i'm curious i bet this exists but
i'm curious who's building like a
mckenzie type of company like a
badass consulting company that is only
tech consulting it's hardcore engineer
it's engineering
specifically around like the new age
stuff of machine learning and ai
and i think that you could build a new
mackenzie deloitte pwc
that is basically when your company
needs
tech when your company needs tech
answers you basically hire this high
price consulting firm
that comes in and these guys are not
suits that are great talkers
these are and make great pitch decks
these are
engineers who come in and they actually
build and they teach your team how to
build and they build themselves
i know that mentor or all these guys
offer that you think they do offer it
but i think
their brand is not branded as this and
so
i think there's an opportunity to come
in and say we dress differently we talk
differently we don't even do
we don't have these 10 other offerings
that mckinsey has we are actually the
best if you really want to hire the best
when it comes to engineering
you know all of our guys are straight
out of facebook google stanford harvard
uh that's our crew and these everybody's
got a computer science degree
you know this is our ceo look he's a
nerd he's got cheeto dust on his shirt
like that's who you're dealing with here
um whereas today i know that mckinsey
and others are like
offering offering these as part of their
services and
in addition to like tax planning and
like 10 other things that they're gonna
do you know like financial audits and
like other [__]
so i think there's an opportunity to
create like a big four
type of consulting company if you just
went all in on engineers
i'm on i'm on board i think it's cool i
i think that any engineer who's smart
though would never want to start this
business because that would be hard as
[__]
but i do think that um there's so many
cool things that started as
agencies that eventually they create
their own software and it becomes badass
so for example i do think it would be
cool to do this for five
ten years and then eventually just make
the software and you could become
it would be a really easy way or not
easy straightforward way to have a
bootstrap software company
so have you ever heard of consensus no
what is it
so consensus is a uh it's it's a tr
it's a version of this um it's in the
crypto space so it was started by this
guy joe lubin who was
like one of the first kind of like six
guys
backing uh ethereum so he was like
he was like ethereum pre-launch i think
he was one of the main funding sources
essentially
he came from the finance world and uh he
believed in ethereum and so he
he's known as one of the co-founders of
ethereum guy basically became a
billionaire off of ethereum
takes the ability he takes that he
basically spins off ethereum launches
and instead of sticking with the
ethereum foundation
he creates consensus consensus is like
we have an office in new york
la shanghai whatever right like tokyo
whatever they like kind of a traditional
consulting model
and um but they weren't just doing
consulting but what they do is they
they had like in-house projects so for
example metamask which is like the most
popular
ethereum wallet i think that's built
into a browser uh was like
either incubated there or they like kind
of like found the guy who built it and
brought him into consensus and that was
one of their projects um
but they basically they make like
they'll go to like mastercard or visa
and be like you guys keep hearing about
blockchain right
don't you need like just a group of
blockchain like specialists who can come
and teach your company how
how you should be using blockchains and
we'll consult with you that will build
projects for you
and like we'll be kind of this like
hybrid like agency
incubator consulting company type of
thing and they do like
i think they said they forecasted like
60 million of revenue in 2021.
um now i should say i personally think
consensus is kind of a shitty company
they hired like a thousand people uh i
don't think they had like the business
fundamentals to support any of that
um you know so so i don't think
consensus itself is gonna be that
successful but
that's an example of somebody who said
cool all of
the fortune 500 is interest is curious
and interested
in this new age technology we can brand
ourselves as
the like de facto group of if you're a
big fortune 500 come talk to us
and we're about blockchain this this
consensus company's [__] nuts
started just recently right oh no 2014.
yeah it started right after ethereum
they do did this guy joseph lubin's
help create ethereum yeah like i said he
he was basically one of the big kind of
like financial backers early on and kind
of helped
when they were pre-launched he was
involved when there was like you know
this
group of seven or eight people that were
helping build it and they each had a
different role
this [__] is creating in such a more
short time is crazy
like do you know that one guy um okay so
what was that disney movie
called like the secret service kid or uh
the first kid
you remember first kid okay yeah i don't
know where you're going
okay you remember that movie remember
the kid actor uh
i don't remember mike he was also in the
movie um mighty ducks oh which one was
he in mighty dex
um i don't actually know what he was in
my
what the name was but his name's brock
pierce okay
do you know who brock pierce is he's
also in sinbad
yeah well no sinbad was the uh the the
lead secretary
security guard first kid okay remember i
remember this movie i love this movie
yeah it's great right okay this guy's
name is brock pierce
he's a bitcoin billionaire now what
yeah dude google brock pierce so he was
a kid
in mighty ducks he plays young gordon
bombay so he's not one of the
the kids he's he's the flashback of
gordon bombay as a kid
yeah but he was like a well-known actor
like he was in um
first kid was a thing he was in little
big league he just did all like the 90s
like kid movies yeah every movie
everyone
if you if you are born in um in the 80s
you recognize who this kid is if you're
31 like me and sam
then you uh you recognize who this guy
is
dude google him he's a bit he was worth
like a billion dollars hilarious you'll
recognize him he's got he's a
bitcoin crypto guy he wears that stupid
hat
he wears a stupid hat now that's just
google i go to images go get brock
pierce
oh okay yeah i've seen him is that yeah
he's a stupid hat leather vest guy like
that's what he wears he goes to puerto
rico dude that guy is a is a billionaire
now
because he was in on crypto in like uh
12 13 14.
he's like he's okay i need to i need all
those royalties from the first kid
we're putting it into eth we'll put it
in the east crown cell
let's do this it's just the amount of
wealth that this is has created and
so quickly it's just crazy um it's just
it's fun it's such a fun story but brock
pierce
the [__] first kid gordon bombay when
he was a kid whatever the guy's name was
he's a bitcoin billionaire billy of the
week
that's it two of my favorite things two
of my favorite things in my life were
mighty ducks and bitcoin
and uh this guy's involved with both of
them now i don't know but
on i read his wikipedia the other day
he's got like some shady [__] going on
where
i mean obviously you kind of look at him
he kind of screams shady but he
like his partner was like raping kids i
mean it was pretty [__] up
and like if your partner's doing that
i'm not saying you're guilty
but i'm saying like you probably like
are involved like
yeah like where there's smoke there's
fire type of thing it's kind of [__]
weird to me
and uh so there's like a this guy's got
a lot of
this guy's going to be like the modern
day mcafee you know like yeah he's just
max v he's like he became a billionaire
and then also like
uh like did some crazy [__] in uh
botswana or where the [__] he went
that's what this guy's gonna do
but anyway brock pierce crazy right
that's crazy
um okay by the way i also have this a
little calculator in excel
that i should publish which is will the
winklevox get the
winklevoss twins get the last laugh
which is what does the price
of bitcoin need to be for them to end up
wealthier than mark zuckerberg for
taking
and taking their idea and making
facebook and uh
and then i thought about it i was like i
wonder if zuck just owned some bitcoin
as a hedge to be like
you'll never you'll never pass me but i
don't think he's got that petty streak
i'm thinking about selling my facebook
stock because i think like i've totally
done 180 i think facebook's whack as
[__] now
but uh why
it's just lame like who uses that now i
mean twitter's just kicking
it's just whack and instagram i think is
even stupid now i love how you're like
who uses that
like a billion people could raise their
hand and be like me every day
multiple times a day i just think that
um it's just lame i think tic toc is so
much better and more positive i like it
more um but i think that um zuck is
someone i would never
bet like i just think that he's just the
greatest in terms of
did you see the video of him spear
hunting recently
no what is he doing oh dude you gotta
google this uh
google mark zuckerberg spear and there's
this video so he like went hunting or
whatever
he went on a hunting trip i think that
might be separate then he's like at this
little like kind of like a throwing
range and there's like a giant target
and then you see mark zuckerberg in
slo-mo running up at it with a spear and
then
launching the spear and getting a
bullseye in the target
and it's just like it's everything you
would expect out of a zuckerberg video
which
is like you know two parts awkward
robotic one part like sort of fearsome
and weird at the same time i'm
yeah i'm looking at it now i mean this
is just yeah wow
he got it by the way you said tick tock
you should um
follow this tic-tac account it's amazing
it's called vitalik doing things
so vitalik who's the co-founder of
ethereum
he's also like zuck like hilariously
awkward
i really love the guy i think he's like
when he talks yeah he might have like
kind of an awkward way of talking but i
love his thoughts i love his brain
basically
he seems like a very genuine guy um he
doesn't just like shill
ethereum and like crypto and say it's
the best thing ever and all that like
he's just like way more reasonable and
clearly like mission driven i'm looking
at it now his story is kind of amazing
by the way like
what's he like like an adopted russian
kid or something do you
do you know how this guy like got
started in crypto no
he's 18 years old he like discovers
crypto
he starts by just he agrees to write
free article or write articles for
bitcoin magazine back when bitcoin was
like super underground at the time
and you know bitcoin magazine paid him
3.50
per article and he's like writing all
about bitcoin and like all the cool
things you're going to be able to do
with cryptocurrencies
he's just like a kid and he used to like
go to different crypto projects and meet
them and be like hey i'd love to like
help or like intern or like kind of like
write about you guys and he started just
getting known as kind of like this
little blogger boy
and then like little blogger boy goes on
to like
he helped write the white paper for one
idea uh
called colored coins that was like gonna
be for this other project and then
eventually decides like you know what
like
i have all these ideas about how i think
crypto could change the world like i'm
just going to make it myself i'm going
to make ethereum
and so he invents ethereum at like age
18 or 19 and like
is the youngest crypto billionaire in
the world um since
where's the name come from russia
what's that mean oh no
oh i don't know why you named it
ethereum um
ether is like kind of like it's sort of
like i don't know if you know what ether
is it's sort of like this
um it's like out of the ether it's like
this like it's like the substance of the
war it's basically
i don't know how you describe ether
really it's like a it's like matter
it's like it's like a word like matter
uh in the universe and so
i don't know why he called it ether i
think it was like
i don't know i don't know the backstory
i should really speculate well you
should have figured that out i thought
you're like
betting your life savings on this um i
saw i took one look at this guy and i
was like i'm gonna hitch my wagon to
this nerd
this this guy's taking me to the top i
think that's a good
i think that's a good bet to be honest
but the tick tock channel vitalik doing
things is amazing comedy
um because he's just a very
unintentionally comedic guy
dan posted it so he goes i immediately
realized that i liked it better than all
the other alternatives that i'd seen i
suppose it was fact that it sounded nice
and it had the word ether referring to
the hypothetical invisible medium that
permeates the universe and allows light
to travel
right yeah that's the guy you want to
bet on
all right i think that's the show right
yeah that's it
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off on the road let's travel
never looking back